we want to share a touching tribute that
a Connecticut man left for his family 32
year old Jonathan Coelho died last week
from cardiac arrest due to the corona
virus when he was hospitalized he wrote
a note on his phone to his wife and two
young children our lead national
correspondent David magno spoke to Co
Ella's wife David good morning Tony
morning Jonathan spent 27 days in the
hospital before he died alone and before
he was placed on a ventilator he wrote a
note to his wife which she read at the
hospital after he died he wrote in the
note what he wanted her to tell their
two children who are too young to
remember their father to his
two-year-old son Brayden who has special
needs he wrote tell him he's my best bud
and I am proud to be his father to his
four month old daughter Penelope he
wrote let her know she's a princess and
she can have whatever she wants in life
and to his wife Katie he thanked her for
giving them the best life he could have
had and then he said this if you meet
someone don't hold back
because if they love you and the kids
like I do then I love that for you you
think he knew I think he did um I think
he was scared that was written the day
before the few hours actually before he
was intubated and we were still texting
and communicating during this time you
don't fight for 28 days and think that
you're not gonna come home so I don't
think he gave up and but I think he knew
that it was gonna be that bad that I
wasn't gonna talk to be able to talk to
him again he knew that I would need
something and my kids are so young and
they're not gonna know their dad or
remember their dad so we're gonna have
to share with them what a great person
he was and I think he wanted them to
hear from him how much he loved them and
how much he cared about them so
beautiful that you you know I hope you I
hope you have what he wrote to you edged
in some kind of
stone or artwork at home somewhere
because those are his final words
written to you yeah and his actually his
best man in our wedding um found my
husband's wedding vows he had emailed to
him the day of our wedding which I
haven't seen or heard since the day we
got married and he sent them to me and
seeing the words he said the first day
we became husband and wife and then the
last words he said to me it just echoed
how much like the love had just
increased and it was just so you could
see from start to finish my husband
worshipped us and I'm so thankful I have
those words but they're also very
haunting because all I have left you
know Jonathan survived childhood cancer
twice and Katie say that says the
doctors told her several times they
thought he was going to pull through in
fact at one point Katie says the doctors
told her his lungs appear to be cleared
of the virus but the virus had wrecked
some of his vital organs Gill oh boy
David it's such a gift that she has
those words and from what I was reading
about the story he was such a fighter
it's so hard to hear it too and it in
her words it is haunting how is Katie
doing how is she going to move forward
did she say stuff you know she $800,000
scale has been donated by strangers to
help her but I was haunted by the fact
that when we finished our interview she
had to start getting the kids ready for
bed because life moves on now that she
is a widow and a single bomb yeah and
Jonathan fought to the very end thank
you very much David